[موسيقى]
التغير المناخي الناجم عن الاحتباس
الحراري بتهما عالميا مؤرقا ظواهره
وتداعياته تهدد ما يقرب من نصف سكان
العالم والحياه الطبيعيه
بمخاطر جسيمه خلال سنوات قليله الاكثر
تاثرا سكان الدول الناميه تؤكد الامم
المتحده ان هذه الدول بحاجه الى ترليون
دولار سنويا لتفادي الاثار السلبيه للتغير
المناخي والعالم العربي ليستثناء من هذا
القلق الانساني عدد من دول يعاني من
ارتفاع درجات الحراره وشرح المياه والجفاف
و تاكل الكيسه وحلها على البحر المتوسط
الذي يرتفع منسوب المياه فيه مهددا مدن
تاريخيه بالغرق منطقه
تكرارا للعواصف الترابيه
ترافقها فيضانات غزيره تحذر دراسات من ان
درجات الحراره في بعض الدول الخليج قد
تتجاوز 60 درجه مئويه بحلول منتصف القرن
الحالي في قصتنا العرب التغير مناخي نرصده
ابعاده هذه الظاهره على سبيل المثال للحصر
في سلطنه عمان التي تعاني زياده في نسبه
الاعاصير المداريه في الجزائر التي شهدت
حرائق في نسيج غاباتها الاطلسي مع معاناه
اراضيها الجنوبيه من التصحر ونت ارتفاع
درجات الحراره والجفاف يؤثر على حياه
الناس والانشطه الزراعيه والاقتصاديه كما
نرسم نرصد الحاله في الاردن حيث علي
المزارعون من شح المياه والامطار نستكمل
بقيه القصه مع ضيفنا الدكتور جاسمين فلاحي
الوكيل الفني لوزاره البيئه
العامه للامم المتحده للبيئه عن اسيا
والمحيط الهادي الدكتور عصام حجي عالم
الفضاء والباحث المختص في دراسته التغيرات
المناخيه بجامعه كاليفورنيا وكاله ناسا
نسال ضيفين عما اذا كان المنافق ومتغيرته
على راس الاولويات في العالم العربي رسميا
وشعبيه وعن تداعيات التغير المناخي على
حياه الناس والانشطه الاقتصاديه وعلى
الاستقرار في دولنا العربيه وعن تقييم
السياسات المتابعه وفرص التعاون المشترك
في مواجهه التهديد المحدق وفق دراسات
عديده لكن لمشاهد القصه بدا ونبدا بعد ذلك
الحوار
الطبيعه لا تعرف الحدود المياه
وجود المزيد من حالات الحرائق
[موسيقى]
الزهور انشطبت كامله لم يبقى في المزرعه
شيء
اليوم المتطرفه
[موسيقى]
شدد تقرير الهيئه الحكوميه الدوليه اعلى
الهيئات الامميه المختصه بدراسه الاحتباس
الحراري وتاثيراته الصادر نهايه فبراير
عام 2022 على الحاجه الماس لاتخاذ اجراءات
عاجله في مواجهه المخاطر التي قد تواجه
العالم في حال ارتفع لاحترار العالمي عن
واحد ونصف درجه مئويه عن مستويات ما قبل
العصر الصناعي وهي الدرجه التي يعني
تخطيها فقدان نصف الكائنات الحيه التي
تعيش في افريقيا ل 30% من اعدادها
واستمرار ذوبان الجليد في القطبين وارتفاع
وتيره اندلاع حرائق الغابات بنسبه 30% في
حال ارتفع متوسط درجه الحراره اربعه درجات
مئويه
ايناس
[موسيقى]
تاتي التغيرات المناخيه الكره الارضيه في
صور مختلفه فهناك تغيرات مناخيه تاتي على
شكل احتباس حراري اي ارتفاع معدل درجات
الحراره السطحيه التغير المناخي دائما
ياتي على شكل انماط ولا ياتي في حاله جويه
ولا يختزل في حاله جويه معينه فمثلا تظهر
انماط معينه منذبان للثلوج في الاقطاب او
فقدان المياه في مناطق اخرى
[موسيقى]
مدمر بشكل كبير وبالتالي الحديث عن
التغيير والمناخي اليوم هو موجود لكن
الخوف من المستقبل انه تغيرات المناخيه قد
تصل لحدود من الاحداث المتطرفه مؤثره على
الامن الاجتماعي والاقتصادي مؤثر عن
النشاط الزراعيه وقد يصل التاثير للامن
الغذائي
الامن الاجتماعي في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]
من عكاسات تغيرات مدى خيار اصبحت
الانعكاسات على جميع القطاعات القطاعات
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والان حتى
التغيرات المناخيه اصبحت واقع نعيشي لكل
دول
الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا التي تشير الارقام
على اقتصادات هي الافقر في العالم فقد
توقعت منظمه كريستيان ايد البريطانيه في
دراسه لها ان تشهد اقتصادات افريقيه
كالسودان وموريتانيا ومالي والنيجر
انكماشا يصل الى
83% من انتاجها المحلي عام 2100 بسبب
التغيرات المناخيه التي ستشهدها المنطقه
وتختبر بعض الدول المنطقه اليوم درجات
الحراره المرتفعه والتصحر الناتجه عن
الشرح المائي كالجزائر والاردن بينما
تواجه دول اخرى كلمه السر وسلطنه عمان
مخاطر الفيضانات والعاصير التي عصفت بشكل
متكرر بنيه البلاد التحتيه
شهدت السلطنه في السنوات الماضيه زياده
نشطه جدا في نسبه الاعاصير المداريه التي
اثرت على سلطنه عمان تشير الدراسات
والاحصائيات ان خليج البنغال في الخمسين
السنه الماضيه كان هو الانشط والاكثر عددا
في تسجيل نسبه الاعاصير ولكن منذ 2007 منذ
اعصار المدارس الذي يؤثر على السلطنه بدات
نسبه الاعاصير في بحر العرب تزيد بنسبه
اكبر مقارنه همم ما يحدث في خليج البنغال
كنا سابقا نشهد في العشر سنوات الماضيه
همم اعصار مداري وعاصفه مداريه ولكن في
خلال العشر سنوات الماضيه بدا تاثير
الاعاصير ونشاطها
كل هذا يشير الى التغير المناخي الحاصل في
العالم
[موسيقى]
مره شتاء و 2022 على الاردن خلافه ما كان
يتمنى المزارع الاردني الذي يواجه الظروف
المناخيه التي ادت الى انخفاض وصل الى 80%
في منسوب المياه في سدود المملكه التي
تحتاج الى 1.4 مليار متر مكعب سنويا من
المياه ويصل العجز الى 500 مليون متر مكعب
حسب تقيمات وزاره المياه الاردنيه
وهذا اعتد عليه لسنوات ولي عشرات السنوات
اما حاليا وبعد مرور 30 عام تقريبا اصبحت
الامطار صحيحه في شهر 12 يعني تقريبا 10
12 لم تنزل قطره ماء فالحمد لله نسال الله
انه يرحمنا برحمته مزروعاتنا تحتاج الى
المياه الوفيره وهذا اصبح غير متوفر
وادى الى غلاء ثمن المياه وارتفاع
تاليف في مدخلات الانتاج ومن اهم مدخلات
الانتاج المياه والمياه الان صارت في شح
فاصبحنا نعطي حاجه النبات يعني الحد
الادنى من حاجه النبات وهذا ينعكس على
الجوده وينعكس على كميه الانتاج مما ينعكس
على الامن الغذائي بشكل عام
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بالمزارع الاردني اليوم تعرض
لظروف مختلفه ومتباينه من التغيرات
المناخيه اذا اخذناها بالترتيب وحسب تكرار
الحدود نعاني اليوم من فترات جفاف وجفاف
ممتد وبالتالي المزارع همم يلجا لدفع
مبالغ اضافيه لتامين مصادر المياه اضافيه
او لخساره الاستثمار يعاني المزارع اليوم
من سرعه الرياح العاليه وسرعه الرياح
العاليه قد تكون مدمره احيانا للبيوت
البلاستيكيه ونستذكر في الاربع سنوات
الماضيه دمار الاف او عشرات الاف البيوت
البلاستيكيه في مناطق الاغوار الاردنيه
بسبب سرعه الرياح
وحتى السكان الجزائر وسكان العاصمه لحد ما
الامطار سقطت الا في شهر نوفمبر من شهر
ديسمبر الى شهر مارس يعني همم لم تسقط
الامطار وهذا يؤدي الى اثر سلبي مباشر على
الفلاحه وحتى اعلى مخزونات المياه في
سوريا
التي مرت بالاردن في يناير ومارس 2020
[موسيقى]
لم نشهد ان يمتد الصقيع واثقا
وتدني درجات الحراره لهذه الدرجات الدنيا
من هذا العام
الزهور انشطبت كامله لم يبقى عندنا شيء بل
اضطرررنا الى انه نجمه بلغه المزارعين
انجب ان اقل من تقليم زائر لهذا الامر اما
على المستوى الخضار والفواكه في منها
انشطب تماما لم يبقى في المزرعه شيء فلذلك
انا خساره المحصول خساره تكاد تكون من 80
الى 100% من بعض المحاصيل قطر التغيرات
الداخليه في الجزائر الشمال جميع المناطق
المناطق الجانبيه في ما يخص ظهرت
في الشمال ايضا نجد ظاهره الحرائق في
النسيج يعني الغابات الاطلسي ولكن سنوات
اخرى
[موسيقى]
حتى الدرجه الحراره تقابلنا درجات قياسيه
لفاقه 55 درجه مئويه وهدد درجات القياسيه
تؤدي الى نقص وجفاف والمدره المياه مستحيل
حتى الانسان ان يعني يعيش مع الدرجات
الحراره مرتفعه
[موسيقى]
التي نعيشها ما يزال هناك من يشككون فيها
ويرجعون تلك الظواهر الطبيعيه الى كونها
انماطا لتغير وتطور دوره الحياه على
ظهر كوكبنا
اوكي
[موسيقى]
ارتفاع
معدل درجات الحراره بشكل كبير جدا وجود
المزيد من حالات الحرائق وحرائق الغابات
وغيرها من علي من الامور ولكن اليوم هناك
واقع ملموس بدانا نشعره نشعر به وهو
ازدياد الحالات الجويه المتطرفه
[موسيقى]
اثار سلبيه لاحدنا في الاونه الاخيره
فيضانات لان تدبدو في الفصول يعني همم عدم
سقوط الامطار بكميه معتدله ولكن سقوط
الامطار بكميات يعني سريعه وهذه الكميات
السريعه تكون تؤدي الى فياضانات
والجزائر فياضانات كثيره على سبيل المثال
الفيضان
2001 وعده فيضان اخرى مباشر
[موسيقى]
اصدر المركز الوطني
للانذار المبكر من المخاطر المتعدده
الرابع
تاثيرات المباشره للاعصار على محافظتي
مسقط وجنوب الباطنه
[موسيقى]
لا تنبؤك طول سواحل سلطنه عمان الجميله
بما تخبئه من مفاجات غير ساره كبدت
السلطنه الخسائر على مدار السنوات اذا
اسفر الاعصار شاهين الذي عاصف بمدن البلاد
الساحليه مطلع اكتوبر تشرين الاول
2021 عن وفاه 13 شخصا الى جانب التضرر
الشديد الذي تعرضت له البنت تحتيه
والمساحات الزراعيه
اعصار شاهين سجل نفسه في التاريخ المناخي
لسلطنه عمان
وبطبيعه الحال سيتذكره الصغير قبل الكبير
كذلك من الاثار السلبيه للاعصار المداري
شاهين اثر على محافظات مكتظه بالسكان منها
محافظه مسقط ومحافظه جنوب الباطنه ومحافظه
شمال الباطنه سجلت خسائر الماليه يصل 240
مليون ريال عماني كذلك اثر نوعا ما تاثير
على البنيه التحتيه
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله ما
شاء الله تكرار الاحداث المناخيه المتطرفه
التي تعيشها عمان حارث السيف لتسجيل
الظروف الجويه الهائله لتلك الاحداث
وتوثيقها بما يساعد على فهم تلك الظواهر
بشكل مقرب ومعاينه لحظات تكوينها واثارها
على النظام البيئي
[موسيقى]
وانا شخصيا احب المواجهه واحب الدخول الى
عمق هذه الاعاصير مطارده الاعاصير جزء لا
يتجزا من هوايه الطقس والمناخ وهو الجانب
الحماسي لنا كهواه للمناخ والطقس
من اصعب المواقف التي واجهتني خلال مسيره
الطقسيه ولما ذهبنا الى المنطقه في
المنطقه الحقيقه كان الوضع يعني لا يبشر
تكونات كانت محدوده وكانت متفرقه وانت ظن
تقريبا من الساعه 1:00 او الساعه واحده
ونصف ظهرا والاوضاع جدا هاديه فقلت اقول
لزميلي ممكن حسن رشه يعني والامطار بعد
عشر دقائق انه ونشوف مثل الزوج عن
الغباريه يعني بس خمس دقائق وتخب ريح
شديده جدا من قوتها الا ونشوف يعني اعمده
الكهرباء تسقط امامنا همم
الزجاج الخلفي بالسياره
وانتظرنا لحد ما تهدي العاصفه وكان الخوف
من السياره تنقل بنشده عاصفه
فجاه يعني خلال فقط نصف ساعه
صارت عاصفه شديده
له عروس البحر الابيض المتوسط عام 2015 من
فيضان اودى بحياه سبعه المصريين وتهجير
مئات الاسر من سكان حي الماكس بعد اعلان
المنطقه غير امنه حسب دراسه نشرها الاستاذ
بكليه الاثار في جامعه القاهره سيد حميده
اظهرت ايضا حجم التاكل الواضح في شاطئ
المدينه خلال السنوات الماضيه فيما توقعت
دراسه لمنظمه اير دوت ار ان يرتفع مستوى
سطح بحر الاسكندريه الى ثلاثه امتار بحلول
عام 2100 ما سيؤدي الى نزوح اربعه ملايين
من السكان وكنتيجه لاختلاط مياه البحر
المالحه بالمياه الجوفيه قد تنخفض الزراعه
في مصر بنسبه
47% بحلول عام 2060 خصوصا تلك المناطق
الواق في دلتا النيل والتي من المتوقع ان
تغمر المياه المالحه اكثر من
2600 كم مربع من اراضيها في الوقت الذي
تسعى فيه مصر التي انضمت اتفاقيه باريس
للمناخ مبكرا لتنفيذ خطه بتكلفه ثلاثه
مليارات جنيه لحمايه جميع المناطق
الساحليه والمعرضه للتعريه في دلتا النيل
[موسيقى]
مستقبل مائي امن يضمن الانتاج الغذائي
والانتاج همم الزراعي المستدام للاطفال
المستقبل لكن تطبيقنا الاستراتيجيات
الموجوده حاليا والسير في بعض المشاريع
الرياضيه قد يؤدي الى مستقبل افضل ومستقبل
امن في وجود التغيرات مناخيه جديده
المجتمعات العربيه فيه نقص للوعي لهذا
قمنا بتاسيس شبكه العمل المناخي بالوطن
العربي الهدف اتحاد يعني يعرفها مستوى
الوعي بين الدول العربيه والعمل على
مرافقه الاستراتيجيات الوطنيه من اجل
مقاومه وايجاد حلول لتغيرات المناخيه
ومعظم الدراسات تشير الى زياده في نسبه
الاعاصير خلال السنوات القادمه لذلك جاءت
توجيه السامي من صاحب الجلاله السلطان
هيثم بدعم وتطوير منظومه الانذار المبكر
في سلطنه عمان
في الحدود لكل فعل رده فعل فاذا حفظنا على
البيئه والطبيعه في الطبيعه حافظ عليها
فهل فعلا المناخ هو راس مسلم اولوياتنا
انا السؤال يعني يحتاج الاعجاب
[موسيقى]
في الواقع في قصتنا بعض
تواجههم معظم الدول العربيه من مظاهر
التغير المناخي وتداعياته الموجه حار
وجفاف في المياه وتراجع في المنتجات
الغذائيه حيث تشهد دول الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا احترارا يعادل ضعفي المتوسط
العالمي وقبل مؤتمر المناخ الذي عقد اخيرا
في شرم الشيخ وصفا تقرير لمنظمه المعنيه
بقضايا البيئه وصفا الوضع في المنطقه
وتناول تاثير التغير المناخي في الست دول
عربيه هي لبنان والامارات والجزائر ومصر
وتونس والمغرب هذا التقرير في الواقع توقع
ان تعاني 80% من المدن المكتظه بالسكان في
الشرق الاوسط وشمالي افريقيا من موجات
الحق وان تتجاوز درجات الحراره 60 درجه
مئويه مستقبلا في بعض مناطق الشرق الاوسط
الخليل ضد الانبعاثات عاليه للغازات
المسببه احتباس الحراري تعد
مصر دوله على الصعيد العالمي معرضه
لتاثيرات اقتصاديه بارتفاع مستوى سطح
البحر على المدن الساحليه والدلتا وتشير
تقديرات متباينه الى انخفاض بنسب تتراوحوا
ما بين 10% الى 60% في غله المصالح
الزراعيه في مصر بسبب ارتفاع درجات
الحراره وندره المياه وزياده ملوحه مياه
الري تحضر تقارير امنيا من ان العراق من
بين اكثر خمس دول تاطرا بالتغير المناخي
وهو مهدد لفقدان 20% من مياهه العقبه في
حال
ارتفعت درجه الحراره بمقدار درجه واحده
بحلول عام 2050 في العام نفسه يتوقع ان
يفقد السودان اكثر من 30% من نتجه المحلي
لتغيرات المناخيه للسبب لنفسه سينخفض
الناتج المحلي اللبناني بنسبه
14% وذلك خلال عقدين المعدل في تزايد ان
لم يتغير الحال وقد فقد المغرب بسبب موجات
الجفاف طولتي اشجار النخيل في الواحات
خلال القرن الماضي والتي كانت تقدر باربعه
عشر مليون نخله اما في تونس فهي مهدده
بفعل انعكاسات التغير المناخي بفقدان
مواردها الطبيعيه ويتوقع ان تواجه نقصا
حادا في محاصيل الحبوب بسبب جفاف نحو
الثلث المساحه الزراعيه بحلول عام 2030
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم مجددا المشاهدين
الكريمين من بغداد الدكتور جاسم الفلاحي
الوكيل الفني لوزاره البيئه
رئيس الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده للبيئه
عن اسيا والمحيط الهادي
بجامعه سودا كاليفورنيا وكاله ناسا اهلا
بضيفين الكريمين لعلنا نبدا معك دكتور
جاسم الفلاحي من هذا السؤال الذي طرح في
ختان قصتنا الليله هل قضايا المناخ وكل
المشاكل المتعلقه هي على راس اولوياتنا
كوطن عربي ونتحدث هنا عن الحكومات عن
الجانب الرسمي كيف تبدو مخططاتنا بخصوص
هذه الظاهره
نعم شكرا جزيلا حقيقه موضوع التغير
المناخي اصبح واحد من المواضيع الاساسيه
والضروريه يمكن سابقا الحديث عن هذا
الموضوع يعتبر موضوع طرفي لي اعتبار
العديد من الدول بانه هذا الموضوع ليس في
سلم اولوياتها ربما بسبب عدم وجود
المعلومات الكافيه او عدم وجود الفهم
الكافي
لخطوره وتداعيات التغيرات المناخيه على
مختلف مناحي الحياه فاعلمون حضراتكم منذ
قرار اتفاقيه الايطاليه لتغيرات المناخيه
كيوتو عام 1992 العراق لم ينضم الى في عام
2009 لكن الرقم انضمام العراق المتاخر انه
بعد العراق بخطوات في موضوع اتخاذ اللازم
فيما يتعلق بمواجهه تاثير التغيرات
المناخيه انا اعتبر بانه العمل الحقيقي
اللي قام به العراق تجاه موضوع التغيرات
المناخيه واعتبارها اولويه في برامج عمل
حكومات هو بعد اتفاق بعد سته تغيرات
المناخيه وكوب 22
عقد في عام 2015 بعد هذا التاريخ وانضمام
العراق الى اتفاق باريس للتغيرات المناخيه
بقانون الانضمام اتفاقيه الانضمام بقانون
الرقم 31 لعام 2021 واللي انضمنا لها رغم
ظروف جاي هتذكرونه الا اننا نعتقد بانه
هذه كانت خطوه مهمه جدا
ووضعنا استراتيجيه وطنيه كحكومه عراقيه
لمواجهه تاثير التغيير المناخي هي وثيقه
المساهمات الوطنيه المحدده الوطنيه وتسمى
بالناردوبيشن عندي سي انا اعتقد بانه
وطبعا هذا ورد اساسا في التقرير او في
برنامج الحكومي اللي قدم دوله السيد رئيس
مجلس الوزراء الاستاذ محمد الشاعر
السوداني الى البرلمان ونال ثقته كان
موضوع التغيرات المناخيه والحكومات القبله
كذلك كان موضوع التغير المناخي هو موضوع
اولي بسبب انه العراق يعتبر واحد من اكثر
خمسه دول في العالم تاثرا في موضوع
التغيرات المناخيه سيده الكريمه اصبح
تاثير التغير المناخي على العراق واضح
تماما وجلي ويمكن لمس لمس اليمين
دكتور جاسم هذا التغير بيت جليا وواضحا
كما العديد من الدول العربيه وهي ظاهره
عالميه في نهايه الامر لا تقتصر لكننا
خصصنا حديثنا الليله عن العالم العربي
اتحول لدفتر عصام حجي ضيفه الكريم من
لاسونج دكتور عصام يعني لماذا كل هذا
القلق من هذه الظواهر من التغير المناخي
والواقع انه منذ قرون ومنذ عصور البشريه
شهدت مثل هذه التغيرات المناخيه الجفاف
الفيضانات وغيره واا يراها البعض بانه نسق
متكرر طوال التاريخ الانسانيه هل تجد في
الموضوع مبالغه ام انه فعلا موضوع مستجد
بما حملته ربما ثورات الصناعيه وتطور
الهائل الذي صاحب مختلف العصور الانسانيه
ده صحيح ده سؤال ممتاز جدا احنا
بنتخيل ان التغيرات حصلت قبل كده وبالتالي
الداعي ان نقلق لانه متكرره ولكن احب نوضح
هنا جزئيه ممكن تفوت بعض المشاهدين ان هذه
التغيرات حصلت على مدى ملايين السنين فكان
للكائنات الحيه الوقت للتاقلم معها ولكن
ما نراه في خلال 50 عاما الفرد ان
التغيرات هي مثلا زياده درجه الحراره كوكب
الارض درجه واحده بدل ما كانت بتتم في
مليون عام فقط في 50 عام والتخلخل الذي
يحدث هذا التغيير في منظومه كوكب الارض
عشان ندي مثال بسيط جدا انت كانسان تخيل
لما لما الحراره عندك بتزيد من 37 ل 38.5
او 39 درجه او اثنين دي بتخليك غير قادر
انك تتحرك وبتقعد في السرير وبتنام كوكب
الارض نفس الشيء هذه الدرجه لا تعني فقط
الاحساس بالحرب لا هي تخانخل في كل منظومه
المناخيه والبيئيه طب في واجابه لوجود جزء
الاخر هذا يحدث في كل اجزاء العالم فاحنا
لا يجب علينا ان نقلق لا احنا نعجب علينا
ان نقلق انه في كل الاماكن التي يحصل فيها
هذا في خطه للتعامل مع تغيرات المناخيه
بينما عندنا في عالمنا العربي لا يوجد
اصلا ايمان بقضايا التغير المناخي وده
شفناه في مؤتمر ال- ال- الكورس الكوب 27
في مصر اللي تحول لمؤتمر لحديث عن السياسه
من يحضر من لا يحضر من في السجن من خارجه
من داخل مصر من خارج مصر ونسينا خلاص
الحديث على قضايا متمس ارواح الملايين انا
متعاطف مع كل هذه القضايا ولكن في قضيه
بتخص قعدت اكبر من الناس ولازم ان احنا
نعطيها حقها ولا تصبح مجرد التجميل احنا
ليس لنا خطه في التعامل مع التغير المناخي
وهذا ما يجعل هشاشه الوضع في العالم
العربي ليس التغيرات
عدم وجود اي خطه للتعامل معها
ينفعونا حقيقه للسؤال هذا الدكتور عصام ان
التقارير الدوليه الكثيره تحدث بالفعل من
التداعيات تغير المناخي في منطقتنا
العربيه تحديدا لكن اذا دققنا في مسبباته
فان الدول الصناعيه الكبرى هي المسببه
بدرجه الاولى لما يحدث كوكب الارض ولما
يحدث للمناخ لماذا يعني همم يعني نتسائل
حقيقه لا يعزز ذلك ربما التشكيك في دوافع
همم هؤلاء من تحضيراتهم التي تبدو مفزعه
من تداعيات تغير المناخي
طيب ده يعني هذه الفكره هي فكره رومانسيه
جدا في رايه وبتجعلنا في مقعد الضحيه انه
هذه يعني هم اللي عملوا هذا هذه الغازات
وانبعثات بالثارات الصناعيه اذا نحن ضحايا
واجب علينا الحصول على التعويضات واذا كان
بنفس هذا التفكير هل يطلب الغرب اوروبا
وامريكا تعويضات من افريقيا على فيروس
الايبولا بعد انتشاره هل نطلب تعويضات من
الصين
على انتشاره هل المنتجات الصناعيه التي
صنعها في اوروبا وامريكا دي لم نستفيد
منها نحن في عالمنا العربي هذا الفكره ان
هم المخطئون ونحن الضحايا فكره خاطئ ويزيد
الطين بل انه لا يحضرنا الى خطه بيئيه
ومناخيه ما يزيد الطين بل هو كل هذا
الكلام ان احنا ليس لنا ارصاد في عالمنا
العربي واننا ليس لنا ارصاد التغير
المناخي نعتمد على النماذج رقميه اللي فهم
التغير المناخي في العقود القابله وهذه
وهذه النماذج فيها بعض المبالغات فيها بعض
الاخطاء وبالتالي قد تكون الصوره قاتمه ما
نحتاجه هو ان نشارك المجتمع الدولي في فهم
هذه الدراسات وفهم التغير المناخي في
عالمنا ليس مسؤوليه الغرب بل هي مسؤوليه
الهيئات البحثيه العربيه التي يجب ان يكون
لها ارصادها الخاصه واقبرها الصناعيه
الخاصه وعلمائها الخاصين احنا دلوقت
بنعتمد على الاقمار الصناعيه الغربيه التي
ليست مؤهله لدراسه التغير المناخي امام
العربي نعتمد على العلماء الغربيين الذين
ليس لهم اي علم بالفيزياء التغيرات فيها
في في عالم العربي وعلماء انا في الداخل
هم وسافرون في الخارج يعني همم يعني انا
لست افضل منهم وليس لنا القدره على الرجوع
للمشاركه في هذه الابحاث او حتى رجوع
العالم العربي غير في صفه في صفه مستقيم
او في الاجازات يعني وهذا لن يحل هذه
القضيه الشركه العامه
بهذا السؤال الدكتور جاسم سمعت الدكتور
جاسم ما ذكره الدكتور عصام هل نولي
الاهميه الحقيقيه للعلماء لان تكون
الدراسات المحليه وتنطلق من هنا اما انا
نلتفي بمؤتمرات في نهايه الامر يلتقي
اساسه يتحدثون في مواضيع مختلفه منها بجزء
بسيط كما ذكر الدكتور عصام يتعلق فعليا
بقضايا همم المناخ
شكرا جزيلا الدكتور عصام على مساهمات
ولكني حقيقه اختلف معه في وجهه النظر بانه
الاحترار العالمي او الاحتباس الحراري في
مؤتمر باريس للتغير المناخي كان واحد من
اهم مقررات المؤتمر هو الذي اكد على مبدا
مهم وهو ما يسمى
مسؤوليه مواجهه الاحترام او التغير
المناخي هي مسؤوليه عالميه مسؤوليه كل دول
العالم لكن مع اختلاف المسؤوليات وعندما
نقول ونؤكد بان العالم الصناعي على مدى
اكثر من 250 300 سنه هو المسبب الحقيقي
لظاهره الاحتباس الحراري اللي حدثت بطريقه
متزايده ومتسارعه خلال سنوات الاخيره
واللي اصبح تاثيرها جدي على حياه وصحه
الناس بل ويمكن ان يؤدي الى انقراض انواع
من النباتات وانواع من الحيوانات مثل ما
مرت البشريه في همم عهود سابقه لكني اقول
بان موضوع التغير المناخي والمسؤوليه
التاريخيه يجب ان لا تجعل انا اتوقف على
موضوع واحد رغم اهميته وهو موضوع الاليه
التعويضيه لاقرها اتفاق باريس نعم نحن
ضحايا للتغير المناخي لاكثر من 300 عام من
النشاط الصناعي للدول الصناعيه الكبرى
والتي استغرق الكبير
ايضا يعني كحكومات وحتى كمواطنين عما يحدث
من تغيرات الانسان جزء من المسؤوليه نعم
بالتاكيد سيده الكريم هو ناتج عن النشاط
الانساني الاحتباس الحراري هو فعل انساني
اضر كثيرا بالبيئه اللي عايش بها
وبالتاكيد نحن نؤكد بشكل جاد على موضوع
العلوم والاكاديميا فيما يتعلق بالتغيرات
المناخيه نحن في المنطقه العربيه وفي دول
هذه المنطقه لم تاريخ خبرات ممتازه جدا
وبالتاكيد لدينا علماء وباحثين بلوا اصبحت
لدينا مراكز متخصصه في موضوع التغيرات
المناخيه واقسام في الجامعات العراقيه
لدينا قسم متخصص في جامعه بغداد يمنح
شهادات للتغيرات المناخيه ولدينا متخصصين
لكن انا اقول بان مواجهه هذه الظاهره يجب
ان تكون على ثلاث حلقات الحلقه الاولى على
المستوى الوطني وهذا يتطلب اجراءات وطنيه
تقوم بها الحكومات لاجراءات حقيقيه ضمن
عطر استراتيجيات ورؤى وسيناريوهات
وحلقه اقليبيه تتطلب تعاون اقليم لمواجهه
تاثير التغير
كموجوده جاسم يعني اخر اجتماع او محفل
التقاسيه المسؤولون العرب حتى الدوليون
كان في شرم الشيخ ما الذي جمعا انتم كعراق
ما الذي خرجتم به يعني هل خرج العراق من
هذا المؤتمر بدعم ما بخطط ما ماذا عن
تنسيق العربي ايضا في هذا المجال هل هو
متوفر
هنالك المجلس التنفيذي لوزراء العرب
المسؤولين عن شؤون البيئه كان لنا لقاءات
تنسيقيه ان احنا نعمل ضمن المجموعه
العربيه
لصياغه الاليات تحاول تخفيف او تقليل
الاثار السلبيه للتغير المناخي الذي هو
حقيقي علميه وحتميه يمكن سابقا كنا نواجه
كبير الكثير من التحديات لجهات اقناع
اصحاب القرار بانه موضوع التغير المناخي
هو حقيقه الكثير من الدول حتى على مستوى
اصحاب القرار كان يعتقدون التغير المناخي
هو تغيرات في الطقس لماذا هذا القلق
الزائد لكن حقيقه نحن الان وصلنا الى
مرحله التطرف المناخي يتطلب اجراءات هنالك
رؤى سياسات تنسيق على مستوى العالم من
المنطقه شارك العالم كله في مؤتمر شرم
الشيخ وبالتاكيد التحدي كان كبير لكن
حقيقه هنالك قرارات مهمه لمؤتمر شرم الشيخ
واحده منها هو ما يسمى باللوشن ده مش بكام
اسم او ما يسمى باليه الخسائر والاضرار
نحن لا نركز فقط على اعتبار اننا ضحايا
لكن حقيقه ان احنا نحتاج الى نقل
التكنولوجيا وتبادل الخبرات والخبراء
لمواجهه تاثير التغيير المناخي واقوى
واحده وكوكب واحد يتشاركه الجميع اتحول
للدكتور عصام الحجي اقعد عند الدكتور عصام
يعني الملاحظ الملاحظ بعد كل هذه همم
ظواهر سواء كانت فيضان او حرائق انها تعزم
يعني يمر الموضوع ولا ننساه يعني مباشره
بعد ذلك يعني الفيضانات يق لانه شبكه صرف
همم المياه هي المسؤوله ال- ال- الحرائق
بفعل فاعل في بعض الاحيان يعني تنسب اليه
ويمر موضوع مرور الكرام وياتي المسؤولون
العرب رغم ذلك ونسمعهم في المؤتمرات
الهامه يحدرون من هذه الظواهر المناخيه
كيف تفسر هذا التناقض
همم اولا في نقطه مهمه طبعا انا عايز اقول
يعني للدكتور جاسم انه احنا تقدمنا على
مستوى السياسات وعلى مستوى
الاجسام الاداريه اللي بتدير هذا الموضوع
لا لا يعوض القصور الموجود في الارصاد
يعني احنا مش ممكن نحل مشكله احنا مش
فاهمينها او بناخذ ارصاد من اماكن اخرى
ولكن بالنسبه لهذه الظواهر احنا نتعامل
معنا معه على علم العربي على انها كوارث
لحظيه قال يعني ان في
الظروف غير سعيده تسببت في هذه الكوارث
وانه سحريا ستزول ولا انت تتكرر ان شاء
الله وانا استمر في حياتنا عادي وعندي
مثال بسيط جدا بيوري قد ايه حتى لو في
ايمان لحظي التغير المناخي اثناء حدوث هذه
الكوارث على مستوى السياسه الطويله الماده
لا يوجد هذا الايمان باي شكل من الاشكال
هات لك مثال مع الرغم ان كل التقارير
العلميه بتؤكد حتميه ارتفاع مستوى سطح
البحر
لكن بننظر في كل الدول العربيه بلا
استثناء الا الاردن لانه ما لوش شواطئ
البحر انه التوسع العمراني بيتم في مناطق
الساحليه البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه من
محطات تحليه المياه من مصادر الطاقه من
المطارات غير وغيره كله بيتم في مناطق
الساحليه اللي هي مهدده انها تغرق
هذه الدراسه في ناقص هذه النقطه تحديدا
لان مهمه لان العديد من الدول العربيه
بالفعل تقع على همم سواحل سواء البحر
الابيض المتوسط
هذه الدراسه اللي احنا علينا ان نبتعد عن
السواحل لبناء منطقه البنيه التحتيه
والصحيح المسؤول بيفكر ازاي بيقولوا
التغير المناخ ده كمان 30 سنه 50 سنه
ارتفاعها سواحل طيب هو صحيح كمان 30 50
سنه لكن انت بتبني النهارده في المنطقه
اللي هتغرق بكره فهل لهذا يعني يعني
ربما تغرق لقدر الله سنه 2500 يعني ليس 30
او 50 سنه يعني ما الذي تقوله انت ربما في
هذه الدراسه
في عندنا بحث بيقول ان اول اسكندريه من
اكثر معدلات سقوط المباني في المدن
المصريه والسبب ذلك تاكل الشواطئ الذي
يكون اسوا بارتفاع مستوى البحر فا ارتفاع
مستوى البحر يسبب مشاكل حاليا ومصر
اسكندريه ليست وحدها كل العواصم العربيه
بنشوف نفس الظواهر دي في تونس بتشوف نفس
الظواهر في دول الخليج العربي يعني انا
هاديك مثال بسيط جدا يعني على هذه الظواهر
الحدود البحريه في منطقه الخليج العربي
بترسمها 200 جزيره تقريبا على مستوى سطح
البحر اذا ارتفع مستوى سطح البحر نصف متر
هذه الجزر الرمليه الصغيره ستختفي يعني
اختفت هذه الجزر واللي بيختفي منها حاليا
هل ستضطر لاعاده ترتيب الحدود البحريه هل
ستضطر لاعاده رسم حقول النفط هي ملك مين
طب الكلام ده بيحصل المحصلش هي الحروب
اللي موجوده في منطقه الخليج العربي كلها
بالصدفه على الجزر زي ابو موسى وغيره لا
طبعا لازم ان الموضوع
همم عشرات من من السنين للاسف الشديد عند
المواد الناقف معك من خلال تجربتك الدكتور
عصام يعني باعتقادك يعني ظواهر تغير
المناخي هل هي واحده في انحاء العالم
العربي ما اكثر المناطق تاثر سواء المدن
او حتى المناطق الساحليه او الريفيه او
الصحراويه وما اهمها هذه الظواهر ان
استطعت ان جميله لها لنا
هي هي اختنا مختلفه يعني في مناطق فيها
نقص المياه التغير المناخي بانعكس على نقص
المياه وتغير مستويات مستويات الامطار زي
دول حط النيل زي مصر والسودان
بعيده عن حوض النيل زي المغرب وتونس وفي
مستوى ارتفاع سطح البحر اللي بيعدل كل
السواحل الرمليه من تونس لمصر ومنطقه
الخليج العربي بالكامل يعني ارتفاع درجه
الحراره ممكن مقدور عليه انك تتعامل معه
لكن ارتفاع مستوى البحر انت تقف امام وحش
لا يستطيع ان يصده اي جيش الا جيش العلماء
فقط هو اللي يستطيع النهارده انه يحميك من
هذه الحرب الذي يعني الذي مش يعني
ستكون فيها الخسائر كبيره الا من نتفق
حالا ونبدا في الدراسه بالارصاد ههه اعود
اليك دكتور جاسم يعني نتحدث قليلا عن
العراق حيث
ما تاثير التغير المناخي على همم مختلف
الامور على مصادر المياه مثلا همم على همم
الانشطه الاقتصاديه خاصه على الزراعه على
التجمعات السكانيه الاوضاع الاجتماعيه في
العراق ومتى توقعات مستقبلا في هذا الشان
نعم شكرا جزيلا حقيقه يعني تاثير التغير
المناخي على البيئه العراقيه كبير مثل ما
قلت لحضرتك نحن مصنفين على اننا من اكثر
خمس الدول هشاشه وتاثرا في موضوع التغيرات
المناخيه في التقارير الدوليه مشكلتنا
الحقيقيه هو لدينا مشكله تتعلق بتناقص
معدلات التساقط البيطري وهذا بتاثير
التغير المناخي لكن المشكله الاكبر هو في
تراجع ارادتنا المائيه اكثر من 90% من
الارادات ما تاتي عبر الحدود هنالك سياسات
للدول المنبع وبالتاكيد هذه المياه
العادره الحدود تناقصت كمياتها بشكل كبير
وهنالك ازدياد معدلات الجفاف وتدهور
الاراضي والتصحر وزياده العواصف الغباريه
بالتاكيد هذا الجفاف وتدهور الاراضي معناه
هنالك ضغط كبير في ما يتعلق بالامن
الغذائي مثل ما تعلمون ذلك شرائح كبيره من
المجتمع تعيش في الريف عامود حياته
والزراعه تربيه الحيوانات اعتمادها على
المياه بشكل كبير مصدر معيشتها كموائل
طبيعيه وبالنت نهائيات التغير المناخي هو
واحد من اهم اسباب النزوح واحد من اهم
اسباب الاضطرابات والنزاعات التي يمكن ان
تنتقل حتى من داخل بلد وتسمح اعبرا الحدود
ولذلك موضوع التغير المناخي هو حقيقه
اصبحت حقيقه حتميه هنالك تاثيرات علينا ان
نعي تماما بانه التوجه
الدكتور جاسم ما الذي اعد من مخططات
لمواجهه هذا التغير المناخي وما ابرز
التحديات التي تقف امامكم ربما في تطبيق
هذه المخططات
نعم بالتاكيد يعني الان الوعي اصبح اكثر
واعيا على مستوى اصحاب القرار وعلى مستوى
العلماء والمسؤولين والمختصين وكجم مختصه
وزاره البيئه هي الجهه المعنيه بالتعاون
مع بقيه الوزارات لدينا لجنه عليا للتغير
المناخي وبالتاكيد لدينا رؤيه استراتيجيه
20 30 لمواجهه تاثير التغيرات المناخيه
اعطينا التزام بخفض انبعاثات الغازيه
بمقدار واحد الى اثنين بالمئه همم بحلول
عام 2035 بوجود
داخل العراق في مختلف القطاعات وخفض
بمقدار 13 الى 15% الدعم الدولي نحن نعتقد
بان مواجهه تاثير التغيرات المناخيه يقتضي
الاستراتيجيات ورؤى واضحه العراق مبتدا
فعليا اجراءات فيما يتعلق
بحقل النفط والغاز وفي حق الانبعاثات
الموجوده في بقيه القطاعات يمكن لاول مره
نحن في في العراق لدينا رؤيه واضحه
للتاثيرات الجلديه والخطيره
في البرنامج الحكومي وخصصت لها مبالغ في
هذا الجانب لكن انا اريد ان اقول الحقيقه
اخرى وهو ان مستوى الوعي باهميه تاثير
التغيرات المناخيه اصبح عالي جدا والدليل
كان الوفد المفاوض العراقي في مؤتمر شرم
الشيخ على درايه كامله ومعرفه حقيقيه
بالتداعيات الخطيره عليكم ان تعلموا جميعا
بان العراق بلد نفطي نحن من اكبر
احتياطيات النفط في العالم واقتصادنا
معتمد بشكل كبير على الانتاج النفطي كمصدر
الرئيس للطاقه وكمصدر الرئيس الاقتصاد
وبالنتيجه النهائيه التوجه العالمي نحو
التقديم الاعتماد على الوقود الاحفوري
يقتضي ان نبدا بشكل جاد وبدانا بتنويع
مصادر اقتصادياتنا وهذا ما يسمى بالاقتصاد
الاخضر المستدامه نحن نعتقد بان التغيرات
المناخيه حقيقه يمكن العراق لا توجد لديه
سواءا كثيره مثل ما اشار بالاخوان ارتفاع
معدلات مستوى سطح البحر يمكن يؤثر على
مدينه الفاو العراقيه لدينا رؤيه واضحه
مثل ما شاب زميل ضيف نحن نعتقد بانه تاثير
التغيرات المناخيه خطير وكبير على المنطقه
وهنالك رؤيه واضحه لتعاون اقليمي نعم
نتمنى ان تكون الرؤيه تصدقها خطط وتطبق
همم يعني هذه الخطط فعليه همم لتفادي
اتداعيات وعن تداعيات تتحول الدكتور عصام
وتسائل حقيقه يعني ما ترصده همم دراسات
عديده من تداعيات لتغير المناخي يطرح
سؤالا كبيرا عن مال الوضع اذا استمر الحال
على ما هو عليه كيف تراه
احنا دلوقتي الدراسات العلميه ما ننظر
اليه في هذه التغيرات مش بس حجمها
وامتدادها ولكن هل هي قابله للانعكاس او
لا يعني هل هي ستستمر في زياده او ستتوقف
في لحظه ما وهل لو احنا نقصنا انبعاث همم
ثاني اكسيد الكربون هل نستطيع ان نوقف من
ارتفاع مستوى
من ارتفاع البحر او انه هذا المستوى
سيستمر في زيدان حتى لو توقفنا النهارده
عن همم لو نقصنا هذه الانبعاثات وهذه
الابحاث ماذا ما زالت تنظر في هذا الملف
ولكن ما نرى انه
يعني ان لم نغير من زياده درجه الحراره
كوكب الارض اقل من درجه ونصف في المئه عام
المقبل فستصبح هذه التغيرات غير قابله
للتغيير وبتعمل حاجه اسمها الدومينو افكت
يعني هتبدا تتزايد وتبدا تتصارع واللي
متصور ان كوكب الارض الاف السنين اللي
فاتت او نقدر نقول العشر الاف
من عام من تاريخ الانسانيه يعني اللي احنا
لسه قدامنا 10,000 عام بهذا المستقبل بهذا
غير صحيح احنا لو استمرنا على هذا الشكل
لا اعتقد ان البشريه تستطيع ان تستمر اكثر
من 300
عاميه ما الذي يمكن ان نفعل لتدارك ذلك
علميا وفعليا وواقعيا هل هناك امكانيه
لازالتي تعديل ربما همم فمال الاجراءات
التي يمكن ال ال المطلوبه على المستوى
الرسمي وحتى على المستوى الانساني على
المستوى الافراد لديهم مسؤول مسؤوليه ايضا
تجاه
البيئه والمناخ
الرساله واضحه انه على مستوى اا العالم
العربي وعالم مستوى دا القاده العربي لازم
ان يتحدوا ان يكون في برامج رصد وفهم
كوارثنا الطبيعيه التي تخصنا نحن وليس فقط
لاعتماد على التقرير الدوليه التي عملت
فيها اكثر من مره والتي يعني بتبسط الاثار
او تستخدم بيانات بتدي رؤيه مش متكامله ده
اول حاجه اثنين لازم يكون في واعي مجتمعي
وليس فقط واعي على مستوى القيادات وهي
مجتمعي ان هذا التغيير هو عدو لكل
الانسانيه وعليه ان يحاربه معا وليس
متفرقين
المستوى المجتمع لكن على مستوى افرد ما
الذي يمكن ان نقوم به نحن كربما بعض
الافعال البسيطه التي يمكن فعليا ان ان
تساهم يعني همم في الحفاظ على البيئه
اعتقادك
الحفاظ على البيئه على مستوى الافراد ده
يعني ده شيء بسيط اللي احنا نقلل من من
استخدامنا للغازات ونحافظ على البيئه
ونقلل من النفايات ونقلل من المعدلات
الاستهلاك وننقص من ثقافه الاستهلاك وكمان
نزود ان احنا نخلي لشبابنا طموحهم يبقوا
في عالم العلم كان النهارده انسان يتمنى
يبقى عالم مناخ يعني وانت تقدري بس بتخيل
ده تقدر تتخيل الصوره المستقبليه ازاي نحل
مشكله ما فيش احد بيحلم انه يكون جزء من
حل هذه المشكله بينما في الغرب يعني هذه
الصوره غير موجوده
اكبر لدى الافراد ويتبعه بعد ذلك خطط
حقيقيه موضوعه على بشكل رسمي من قبل
الحكومات اشكرك جزيل الشكر دكتور عصام حجي
عالم الفضاء الباحث المتخصص في دراسه
التغيرات المناخيه بجامعه سودا كاليفورنيا
وكاله ناسا كنت معنا من لوس انجلوس كما
اشكر جزيلا الشكر دكتور جاسم الفلاحي
الوكيل الفني لوزاره البيئه العراقيه النا
سابق لرئيس الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
للبيئه عن اسيا والمحيط الهادئ فتى
محلقتنا هذه من برنامج القصه بقيه نعود
ونلقاكم باذن الله الاثنين القادم عن بقيه
بقصه جديده السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]